Thank you very much for your answer. Proof of the pudding is in the eating.
So what we do is we simply press run and we press run again and we see--
we get an assertion error and indeed it is the post condition of square root that has failed.
So the correct answer is the reduction square root post condition fails.
So we saw that the post condition of square root mainly squaring the square root
equals the origin of value failed.
This is weird because all we use--we invoke the standard square root function of Python.
Does this mean that Python square root function is wrong and now finally,
through systematic random testing, we found the bug.
Let me show you what's actually going on in here.